[Applause]
tonight yes let's go with the starter
good evening four ex-army officers
you're all used to pressure
you served in iraq yeah clearly you're
all very used
to giving out orders yeah tonight
there's only one person giving out
orders that's me
yes you've got four ladies lancaster
lassie standing in between you
and the final at claridges yeah you
should really do better than that
yes yeah uh ed what's on the menu what's
on the menu we've got uh summer frittata
gordon
we've got rose duck west with uh fine
green beans and sturdy potatoes
and we've got a baked alaska wonderful
thanks and
now perfect [ __ ] potato i'm gonna do
one with you now get the pan hot
bacon in first yeah what's next onions
onions
onions that's right asparagus in yeah
cheese in
egg mix at the bottom the secret is have
it a little bit runny in the center
but not liquid yes ghost cheese over
asparagus tips
under the grill bang in the idea of that
is to melt all that
ghost cheese look and it's a really nice
sort of
creamy textured frittata yeah okay first
table's on
okay so chris and charlie yes on all the
four covers table five four p
asparagus pancetta frittata four duck
four baked alaska
yes sir excellent well done tonight's
brigade is ed
charlie adam and chris the army boys
let's go guys please
we've known each other for about five
years we've all served in various parts
of the world we've been in some pretty
tough times together very passionate
about eating food i really like my food
tuna steak monk fish cut yourself here
no not yet
i think we got a really good chance of
uh beating the uh lancashire lasses we
will beat the competition
i think we can definitely beat them
every day i think we might as well go
into hiding
um we're going to win it um and we're
going to get clarity's
[Music]
i know they're fussy out there so be
careful yes make sure you get some
really nice colour on those layers
okay more salad please gently just a
little bit over there
they're very nice good chris okay now
would you pay for that
i would certainly play yeah good they're
very nice table five go please well done
i saw bits of black in there now what is
all that in there we do need to make
more
for four no you're real bright guys look
you know what we're not gonna serve that
okay they can't hide it under the
under the nose no we can't hide [ __ ] off
come on okay all the same size start
again [ __ ] it's not just the meat
for my land that i'm going to be using
in the restaurant
[Music]
it's hard to believe they're going in a
week i've been looking after my sheep
for three months
since they were just six weeks old it's
amazing how friendly they've become
isn't it
when we first got them they were like
running away
i now have to turn my thoughts to why i
kept the lambs in the first place
to serve them in my restaurants and
today we're going to weigh them okay
i want to make sure that we've got
sufficient meat on there
yeah all right here we go should we wait
daddy
yeah yeah no chance yeah
right listen listen seriously if you
want any pocket money
open the bloody door guys matilda
jack come on buddy you know that's your
best mate
i'll be serving my lambs to 50 paying
diners they've been bulking up on grass
and hard feed
if they weigh anything above 30 kilos it
means it's all been worth it
[Music]
i know i'm holding it i've just got my
knees caked in [ __ ]
there you go okay what does gavin weigh
35 kilos that's great
yeah gavin's across welsh 50
and 50 charlie so 100 chevrolet are
always going to be a lot bulkier
great weight for gavin yes fantastic
that was easy wasn't it
right one more task yes do you see all
the poo poo everywhere
i need a bucket full of poo guess what
we're gonna make paper
how do you know it's a secret
that's a big one
is 100 poo oh yeah smell yeah
right we're going to meet a poo man
i don't want to waste anything so we're
going to make quality paper out of my
lamb's poo
then i'll print the restroom menus on it
the night my lambs are dished up
what's the first stage well the first
thing we've got to do obviously is
sterilize this the last thing we want to
be doing is handling something that
might have any uh pathogens in it no
germs
we need to extract the fibers from the
poo to make the paper
all right on she goes sterilize i've
never
ever cooked boo before are you okay with
that in the washing machine
it's a bit late to ask you permit no no
but i mean just make sure my socks
aren't in there
wash okay here we go examine
[Music]
blitz pour spread
lift rest throw
[Music]
we're making paper okay concentrate peel
oh mango come on lily
pie come on lily sheep paper
done nice now that's good enough for the
menus at clarity isn't it
it was very fresh it was very light the
vegetables were perfectly cooked
above all it was jaina's shape
i'm speaking french
right results that's the target to beat
yes
yep
okay the number of fanatics that are
prepared to pay for their startups
yep 33 out of 50
ouch that is exactly the same number
as the lancashire lassies so you're on
target you've been under pressure before
yeah now you're under even more pressure
yeah get it right for the duck yeah
okay let's go main course
next on the menu i give cat dealy a
mouthful
look you put weight on but i mean i'm
not calling your family has your wife
taught you nothing
and how to look good naked got one gives
me some fashion advice
what is going on with those [ __ ]
cardigans you don't like my cardigans
they're bonfire food
welcome back to the f word time for the
main course
[Music]
duck normally burnt to a cinder or
stuffed inside a pancake roll
what a waste it's nice and light and
gamey absolutely delicious
score season
five spice quite generous with the five
spice this makes the duck
really aromatic dry pan
fat side down push it down in the pan as
that fat starts releasing itself
from duck breast get a pan now save that
fat
that's duck fat delicious for sauteed
potatoes
honey soy sauce
for me the most important thing now is
the duck stays nice and pink
absolutely stunning
[Music]
green beans perfect accompaniment with
duck
into boiling water literally one and a
half minutes hazelnuts
these are dried roasted hazelnuts more
intense flavor
season crush
beans nice and crunchy when the beans
are warm
they take on the vinaigrette olive oil
hazelnut oil cherry vinegar
[Applause]
[Music]
delicious
slice
lovely honey roast up with hazelnut
green bean salad
done [ __ ] delicious nice and hot yes
it's so easy there's three things on
here duck beans potatoes
couple of spoonfuls adam fine that's it
garlic in there
cook with noise yes yeah how many of you
got there ed says four goals good that's
what i asked for good
beans please yeah the beans fours table
eight please yes these are that
beans beans all potatoes one of them
yet they're not cooked they're not
brought in they'll taste them then come
on
let's taste them don't turn them away to
put them back in the water very very
quickly
adam there's crunchy and there's raw
yeah okay oh
it's oscar now a handful of beans on
there
okay good right stuck on chris come here
are you happy with them
yeah there's some of the cuts are a bit
dodged but i'll show you again we're
going to slice it okay we'll use a
carving knife yeah
this just wasn't shown enough okay go
please table five yes
right adam i want the [ __ ] beans
please yes yes sure
you're still not cook come on back in
you've got no [ __ ] water in there
yeah yeah always keep that pan of water
boiling out on there yes
[ __ ] how sure you can cook the bean
my man [ __ ] awesome all right let's
go
hey it'd be really nice you could save
your food yes yep right stand there
pissing your [ __ ] knickers let's go
service please sorry to keep you waiting
time to cook beans four [ __ ] times
nothing to laugh about
yes table egg let's go
[Music]
kangaroo they're sustainable and
delicious but sadly
no one wants to eat them because they're
so [ __ ] ugly
conga eels are monstrous creatures they
can grow up to 10 foot long and can
weigh up to 250 pounds
thousands of them live in the sea around
britain and it's a waste not to eat them
i've come to exmouth to meet dave curley
he's one of the few people i could find
who fishes for congas
and he sells it in his fish and chip
shack tell me what when was the last
time you got your haircut
ah weeks ago right
huh good luck duran duran huh
these things are huge aren't there i
mean it can be completely different to a
freshwater reel
related to the same family but they're i
mean they're humongous yeah yeah
i've seen hundreds a
often live inside wrecks so we're
heading out to sea to fish over one
the fascinating thing about congregails
yeah they look
[ __ ] ugly they are ugly looking but
you cut through that flesh and it's
white gold it's just it is lovely and
it just hasn't quite got the flavor of
cod but
you're gonna prove me wrong with that
we'll be catching the congas with rods
which is going to be a real challenge as
they're very difficult to fish
so it's going to be a slow tuck tug tug
and then bang bang yeah
what do you know
they're on they're they're ferocious
aren't they ah it's non-stop it is
actually physically very tiring to get
one up to the surface
congas are tricky to catch because they
live within the wreck they come out to
take the bait and then nip back into
hiding
yeah oh he's got something on there damn
fucker's gone just come off there damn
i load up my hook with more bait and try
again hold on
they're fighting yeah this is definitely
on here gordon is it oh it's gone
oh [ __ ]
why are they coming off so [ __ ]
frequently
it's frustrating but exciting at the
same time he's on
jesus christ they're so strong oh there
is
[Music]
fantastic [ __ ] what size is that has
casserole size i call it bloody hell
that's not bad is it not bad at all no
god they're so strong
[ __ ] it we'll go absolutely
right now yeah i think if you just jump
them straight across there
these buggers can really bite so the
quickest and most humane way to kill
them
is to sever their spinal cord that's it
that's it jesus christ you got him
i think you got him bully base is one of
my favorite french fish dishes
but i want to create a british version
using conga to show dave and his
customers
that this eel can be even more delicious
so we'll season it first
okay and start the process of a congaree
or bulla bays yeah
very similar to a classic french bully
base but no grey mullet no monk fish no
prawns no lobster
just ears congo pure conga olive oil
then add a little black pepper
salt and saffron oil in skin side down
into the pan and this one will start
getting the
vegetables going nice hot pan add some
olive oil
fennel carrots celery and styronese
crush a whole garlic
add a handful of shallots and lastly
cayenne pepper
that puts a little bit of heat inside
the soup and really helps to season
give a little stir from it please
so we can take down we've got a color
there that's all we wanted on there
fishing but it smells amazing lovely
just lays the pan with a little bit of
pernod
don't sit down set faster
turn off the alcohol and mixing the
vegetables
yeah and the fish evenly
add a splash of wine fish stock potatoes
fresh tomatoes
basil and parsley to finish the dish
cook it out for 20 minutes and then
we're going to blend it
that's all right
okay should we go yes look at them all
fish and chips is off the menu yes
[Music]
we love conga it's so frustrating that
we do not eat enough congoril so
please start buying it because in there
they clearly loved it it may be ugly but
it's [ __ ] delicious
thank you very much cat how are you i'm
good how are you doing
nice to see you nice to see you see you
nice absolutely fabulous thank you
i'm enjoying dinner i am you know so far
yeah it's all good
very good how long have you been late uh
i've been out there for just under a
year so i've um
bought a house out there food wise
what's it like out there what are you uh
what are you eating on
you know what i pretty much eat anything
look you put weight on since the last
time i saw you and maybe i have
in a nice way no we're not enough your
wife taught you nothing no no but i mean
i'm not calling your father anything
you look great you look great within a
bit of weight on it's fantastic
you know what i'm very lucky that i kind
of don't have to worry about it too much
please we are obsessed with food out
there
yeah but no one seems to drink which is
terrible
i order a glass of wine at lunch and
it's like check out the alcohol i know
check out the brit in the corner
that's our second sip of wine but you
still drink don't you yeah
yes favorite drink oh well for me
it's always champagne lovely girl's best
friend
well no it's just for me there's
happiness in every bubble you know it's
one of the ways there's a lot of bubbles
in the glass champagne
exactly as a country now we're the
second largest
drinkers of champagne outside france you
are a font of image i don't know it's
just it's all up there now
jb right little challenge now yes
um i've got a series of champagnes and i
want you to taste them all
and see if you can spot the difference
between them this is not a
test this is a really nice way of sort
of you know understanding champagne
better
have a little taste
second one
[Music]
i i i prefer that one because it's
actually a bit more kind of
bubbly and sparkling absolutely spot on
because that
is an expensive one tattensur the one
you liked and that's a
cheap sparkling wine yeah at 4.99 you
spotted it straight away
you know did i yeah because the most
exciting thing about champagne it's got
those tiny bubbles
that rise from the base of the glass all
the way up constantly
and sparkling wine has a lot bigger
bubbles and they disperse quicker
literally yeah well done do you think
it's fantastic
so this is a vintage champagne and a
non-vintage champagne
oh god okay can you tell the difference
a little bit more difficult
obviously in terms of age um a
completely different
set of grapes
i'm going to be pissed
[Music]
that one okay
you're right they're both lovely
absolutely lovely vintage
and non-vintage now the big difference
between vintage and non-video champagne
is that vintage champagne is a lot
stronger and richer in flavor
complexity comes with age right number
three is quite interesting this one okay
yes now they're both champagne right
horns are cheap
brand and one's an expensive brand right
it's really important not just to focus
on label and by the label
what do you think i definitely prefer
that one
uh why do you prefer this one because
it's lighter and
are you gonna call me cheap now so you
preferred the cheap one
i did prefer the cheap one so do i the
own brands
produced by the supermarkets often come
out on top in competitive wine tastings
it's nice now the secret of opening
champagne is making sure it's open just
with a little sort of
whisper at the end okay no no no i like
the pop
it's the thing that signifies woohoo
and just a small twist nice
slowly and then just come to the end and
just tilt the cork
yeah right i'm gonna show you um a
really exciting way of opening a bottle
of champagne yes okay
yes yes right this is nice to meet you
hello
this man is an expert an amazing expert
and um opening wise a completely
different way yes
indeed indeed it's exciting so they
started opening champagne like this
napoleonic wars time yes the cavalry was
sort of waiting to go into battle
take a bottle out of the saddlebag and
chop away if the french soldiers can do
it i'm sure we can hear in the f word
right ready
saber on there never take it off the
glass right slide it straight up and the
way it flies
slowly or fast quickly like that quickly
like that yeah off again three two one
[Applause]
i think you have to have a go there you
go sunday lunch will never be the same
here we go
right right yes oh so you lay the
sword flat on there either way you just
you just go up there with one two three
and
bang away you go am i doing it
completely unreal just like that
why not off we go one two three
and we have to say to you oh in the name
of noah father of the vine
of saint vincent the painters
individuals i hereby declare that you're
a surprise of the conferee du sabrador
fantastic uh uh actually what are you
going down at money for oh you have to
thank you so much you're welcome buddy
nice to see you guys about the kitchen
see you next time good to see you by the
way
do you want your weapon back okay
i'm left here on my own with bottles of
champagne and a sword
meat was delicious really well cooked um
quite liking the little hazelnuts on the
beans it's a bit of an
interesting touch i'd say the duck was
extremely well cooked
in the sense that it's nice and tender
still holding itself together and it
tastes great
right guys results of the main courses
okay good right chris how do you think
you did
well i think we did well actually yeah i
think we had a few hiccups yeah
slow but good yeah yeah okay jb results
26 out of 50.
guys disappointing that's not so good
feedback from the customers what do they
say
so a bit slow and the green bean is a
bit oily that was a vinaigrette it
wasn't oily yeah greasy it was like a
really nice hazelnut vinaigrette women
hearts please
tough customers out there tonight you're
more than capable of getting 50 out of
50 for the dessert yeah
don't be down and out come back
next on the menu got one laser on a
plate for me in the recipe challenge
are you flirting with me absolutely
i cook up the ultimate dinner party in
under 30 minutes
where's that [ __ ] gato in the bin
and finally after wading through
hundreds of audition tapes i've invited
50 female cooks to the restaurant
tasted their dishes and soon i'll be
choosing my favorites
three of you are gonna show me who
really is the best of the best
welcome back to the f word time to find
out who's got amazing taste and
a sense of style in the kitchen and who
is got wan
ready you you bet your ass i'm ready no
oh dear
so my cook off with gordon i am doing a
family recipe which is a prawn
and chinese mushroom wonton in a soup
noodle and it's all about the prep of
chinese food
it's not about the cooking time so dogs
doing a wonton soup and i'm doing
something very similar but i'm going to
do a bit of a sort of
wonton soup but mixed with a little bit
of sort of hot and sour and then
make some nice wontons but with some
fresh garlic in there so we can just
sort of glamorize it a little bit uh can
i just say you've got bloody good knife
skills there
yeah a lot of time in the kitchen yes
you know what my dad has been in
catering all of his life and
he's actually got a fish and chip shop
in leicester now but really i was
brought up in the kitchens and i was
brought up in the restaurant
and from a very early age yep dad was
teaching us you know how to cook
and how to look after the restaurant so
okay it's a massive part of my life
really after that's fantastic you have a
fascinating background with food because
when you're younger you used to be a
little bit porky
which i find hard to believe no but no
hold on but yeah thank you
i was a chunky monkey once i got up to
just under 18 stone right okay
six years ago just constantly eating not
looking after myself and yeah yeah i
find it hard to believe because you're
you know you look good all my family are
big still
and you know and i was and i was 21
stone at my biggest weight and i'm not
yeah i was a big guy you know i never
had a really bad relationship with food
no
it's just that we were surrounded by and
the chinese culture is anything you do
whether it's a
celebration a commiseration doesn't
matter what you're doing eat meat
alongside it so that i mean that was
that was it really
i'm gonna make the stop first these are
uh prawn heads we're sweating off with
some garlic
some chili ginger lemongrass once i've
made the stock
i'm going to put the prawns back inside
and poach the prawns inside the stock
finish with the coriander
noodles spring onions and some little
beautiful
bok choy got and what's in the pot now
i'm going to make a stock out of the
prawn heads and the tails
because that's what's going to make most
of the soup watching you work in the
kitchen it's almost like watching a chef
you know that huh oh really yeah but
you know i like that you're attentive
you're taking the [ __ ] out of the
oh my god you know what i was just
thinking when you were talking then this
is the
rankest job i would much rather be
putting naked women on buildings than
doing this i'm telling you
guys you do have the most amazing job
you are the luckiest man in the world
i love my job i love clothes i love the
idea of image you know and it's about
making people feel good
sure not changing them whatsoever not
rocket science yeah
it must be a huge turn on well you know
what not really my bag i have to be
honest
um have you ever been sort of tempted to
sort of change direction
no do you know what i i love penises i
mean i can't i'm not going to lie to you
now i do
you know i am gay i'm very very happy
about i'm out to my family which is you
know the biggest part of my life
yeah more than anything else you know me
liking guys has got absolutely nothing
to do with my job whatsoever
do you think they feel safer because
well of course they do because i'm not
trying to hump
them and there's no you know there's no
competition with them it's always yeah
you know we do want a job and
and that's yeah that's pretty much it
isn't it okay i've got some ginger in
there a little bit of garlic fresh
scallop coriander
and a little bit of lime juice i'm just
gonna bind that together
lightly season it and put it in between
the wontons and then poach them off
so what i've got so far then a little
bit behind but it's fine i'm still gonna
win
i have the uh filling for my one tons
which is basically the mashed up prawns
bamboo shoots water chestnuts
and the chinese mushrooms which is the
very very good quality chinese mushrooms
and you know what i have to say you are
one of the gentlest
nicest men i've ever met in my entire
life you really are thank you
are you flirting with me absolutely
[ __ ] lutely i hear that you've got a
little fair shouldn't you
uh yellow what is going on with those
[ __ ] cardigans jordan they are
absolutely heinous can i just say you're
swearing more than me
terrible i swear to god i don't care
i don't care honestly they're not
they're bonfire food i'll dump the
cardigans okay
you know image and clothing it's got to
be representative of who you are as a
person right absolutely and the
character you give off with your
clothing
yeah um to me it's a bit slowny a bit
slowly i grew up in a counseling
the thing is you give off fight
impression that's what it looks like
from a lot yeah from an unlocker
and you know what you'd have a lot more
knickers in the post if i saw it at your
wall you're just trying to distract me
now so you can win you know that without
blaming your dad in case you lose what
you're wearing now let me see
oh no i just got uh chest trousers on
shoulders exactly see how much money
have you got and you're wearing chest
trousers
because i'm ashamed so just to make sure
we maximise the flavor in this stock
with these um heads or the prawns i'm
gonna crush them now because inside that
head is where all the flavor is
do you know about noodles uh i love
noodles these are just egg wonton
noodles but nice
consistency is just absolutely amazing
oh this is really hard talking and
cooking at the same time
um right they've both got a simmer now
for what 10-15 minutes yeah yes
we come back but then you lose what
[ __ ] ever now it's time for dessert
baked alaska absolute classic everyone's
heard of it but no one knows exactly
what's inside
basically layers of sponge ice cream and
then wrapped in meringue but
a special meringue italian meringue
sugar water
bring that up to the boil and cook it
out for three minutes
egg whites lemon
that strengthens the egg wine
[Applause]
for the sugar half of the sugar in pause
for 10 seconds
and the other half in classic
italian meringue look beautiful
[Music]
ginger sponge lovely
cut
[Applause]
raspberries raspy liqueur
be quite generous with that ice cream
[Music]
[Applause]
and then your second sponge push that
down
now meringue into the bag
[Applause]
[Music]
pipe
into the freezer 10 minutes to get nice
and solid
[Applause]
[Music]
cognac
[Applause]
[Music]
from flambe in front of your very own
eyes
[Music]
bait alaska done
baked alaska in the dining room yeah
come back with 50 out of 50. let's go
yes let's go up right guys let's go up
here we go
we've got these two coming up first well
i'm pretty excited too
thank you very much guys hope you enjoy
it sorry you didn't get chris guys
but i will send them over i hope you're
not wearing too much hairspray
do you see the flowers oh my god it's a
bit hard in the light but they're there
i promise
that's where he was there we go we got
it going here
thank you girl perfect however fast your
life is there's always time
for good homemade food
dinner parties can be hell the pressure
to perform well in the kitchen
means menus are often safe or stuck in a
time warp
i tend to cook a three-course meal
starts off with prawn cocktail spaghetti
bolognese and then we tend to have a
frozen dessert chocolate gato
to cook a nice meal and be adventurous
you need to have time to be able to do
that and at the moment i just don't have
the time to do that
cow's been cooking like this for 13
years i'm here to show a dinner party
menu
that can be done in under 30 minutes
dinner parties a [ __ ] chef's
nightmare
that looks like cat food in there what
is that no this is spaghetti bolognese
run me through the spag bowl spag bowl
pasta yup spaghetti
mince tomato run me through your
bolognese sauce
that is my bolognese sauce though what
do you mean that's it the tin the jar
sauce onions vegetables no onions
vegetables garlic no
straight onto the spaghetti 13 years
carol
three months fine but 13 years cooking
the same old [ __ ]
that let's start off with that in there
go in there yeah we're gonna do three
dishes
salmon chicken and a cheesecake that can
be done easily
whilst you get ready and lay the table
at the same time right first of all
we're going to do the salmon
it's on my menu at the restaurant
perfect for summer very very light as a
ladies dish
so we'll get the marinade done first uh
spring onions
while you're doing that i'll chop the
chili and the nice thing about this it
can vary you know that you can put
chopped ginger in there
as you get a little bit more adventurous
i'd like to think over the next 13 years
that's exactly what you're going to do
add finely chopped coriander the juice
of one lemon olive oil
sesame oil and soy sauce now that
is the most difficult part done all
right okay and it's quicker to do that
than is make a prawn cocktail
[Music]
don't dress the salmon with the marinade
yet put it in the fridge and start the
main course
chicken a simple dish with chicken creme
fraiche and capers
always go to the outside of the pan
first that is really nice and hot
that's it so everything will go in here
so there's not any other pan that i need
no we have one pan and one panel one pan
for the husband to watch out when he
gets home yeah
when you've got colour on both sides add
some white wine
after two minutes take out the garlic
and rosemary and put some capers in
chicken stock creme fresh in bring it up
to the ball
and we need it happy with that
straightforward so quick
quicker than bolognese very quick the
beauty of this chicken dish is that you
can leave it to finish
while you lay the table when was last
time i made a cheesecake
time for dessert and no baked cheesecake
this is going to wipe the floor with the
gatorade
start creaming it for me please just
squashing it in that cream in it right
six tablespoons of sugar fresh
vinegar three-quarter whipped
cream just taste that now with the
vinegar in there
[Music]
lovely add the vanilla cream to the
cream cheese mix
next creme de cassis a black currant
liqueur
i know you girls like alcohol
so everyone thinks cheesecake has to be
long-winded but look
now where's that [ __ ] gato
in the bin right look at you old lamb
right this menu is so quick cows even
had time to get changed
before her guests arrive oh
you finished them yeah and i'll get
ladies in
and sat down it's the prawn cocktail
girls
come in come in come in come in nice to
see you wine in hand i see my darling oh
jesus pissed already
i wish take a seat huh twice it's like
the calendar girls
right take a seat
now there's no prom cocktail there is
there no that's not yeah
i don't think they'll be upset do you
better than normal oh
ladies good to see you sorry about the
porn cocktail but they're gone we're
gonna have to wait another 13 years for
another one
for the last two months i've been
offering the women of britain a chance
to have their very own slice
of the f-word thousands of passionate
female cooks have applied and now it's
time to put my favorites
to the test
good evening right
which one do you fancy
oh god right nina calm down get yourself
a glass of wine my darling yes
okay good now listen the good news is
that you lot yes we're the best of the
best
out of the thousands of female cooks
that applied to be in my kitchen
and three of you are going to show me
who really is
the best right here in my kitchen
ravinder bogle
i've got some coriander my absolute
favorite herb
denise polyfill
straight in there now i'm tempted to
drink it myself but no we'll put it in
the dish
the mascara gemma hammer
my top tip is to crack the egg and to
gently hold it over
with some of the whites coming out just
so it cooks
first now it's time to see what you like
under pressure
you've all got 20 minutes blow me away
with something exciting
[Music]
ravinda what are you gonna cook tell me
i'm gonna do this piece of chicken
stuffed with chopped mushrooms lemon
zest lots of garlic
and lots of chopped coriander good gemma
what are you going to do i'm going to do
tuscan chicken which is lemon thyme
rosemary
basil sugar fill nice good good good
denise what are you doing daddy i'm
going to do chicken with a bit of a
spanish flavor
we've got some peppers got a shallot bit
of garlic some of the paprika
lovely
all right that looks nice so you're
roasting it with lemon herbs garlic and
you're going to put some fennel in there
how are you gonna roast it i'm just
gonna roast it with chili and olive oil
what did you learn to cook well when i
was about five years old my mom said to
me if you don't learn to cook now
you'll never get married and everybody
and you're married with children right
no
that's the irony i can cook but i
haven't found a husband
[Music]
don't you film that let's not care what
you put in there turmeric
i've got in there yeah okay
i probably didn't want it quite so
worried hey ho
ready to plate up yes ravinder denise
yeah i think let's go yes
now my three fannies have cooked they're
amazing dishes and it's time to find out
how good it takes
on the right-hand side here angela
harland one of the best female chefs in
the country and mark sergeant
my right-hand man at clara juice right
uh gemma um what have you cooked please
well my tuscan chicken
and then i deviced it fennel with chili
lovely
do you get that spicy as soon as you eat
it so it's slightly overpowering
it's not delicious though i love the
fennel because the fennel's like um
you're right about the sugars and yeah
it's brought out the sweetness of it
it's really nice
and for me slightly hot i'm told that
i'm an awful yeah it's a bit too hot i
like the lemon in there
okay good ravina tell me about your
dishes i did some chicken
stuffed with chopped mushrooms garlic
lemon zest
lemon juice and balsamic vinegar
reduction
presentation wise yeah very neat thank
you you know as well you've got that
sweetness at the end haven't you but
it's nice you saw it's about salmon yeah
you love it it's really
nice the lemon goes really well with it
yeah just just
together fresh as well great seasoning
now delicious
denise tell what you've done right i've
done a sort of spanish style chicken yes
saffron rice tomatoes garlic shallots
excellent
sarge first impressions of that meaning
rice is nice got a really nice texture
i got slightly nervous when you put half
a tin of turmeric in the rice but i was
pretty nervous
when i saw that rice yeah it's getting a
little bit too crispy unfortunately
yeah yeah burnt apart from that
impressive
what i like about all three dishes that
you worked on it
yeah i said to you get the idea and
evolve it and i think you just
did that so i made my decision
the woman that i want
to be my fanny is
dessert next week yes yes well done oh
okay big round yes
let's go
[Applause]
next on the menu he may know how to look
good naked but
can got one beat me in the recipe
challenge fancy
honest winner loser
and there's a final twist as i take my
lambs to the slaughter
last thing on my mind right now is
[ __ ] shepherd's pie
[Music]
right welcome back to the f word now
time to find out who has won the recipe
challenge
nervous [ __ ] my [ __ ] look at me i'm
shaking
but what you've done to me poncy honest
winner loser jb come back with the good
news
yes and you know what if i don't when
i'm not sleeping with you just consider
that
so dish number one number two
thank you oh quite strong definitely
it's quite it's very light though don't
cook very well though yeah though they
are brilliant
the texture is quite nice instantly says
coriander yeah
it's really strong that's really nice
and there's actually
there's a lot of flavor in them bring in
the good news
yes okay uh the winner
and i'm quite happy actually
oh yeah
[Laughter]
oh god come back i hate you listen
listen listen
what grounds um i want to re-eat i had
to say
coffee in the kitchen in chinese
in the kitchen yeah something like that
now get out of here
love you so much yes commiseration
it's time to say goodbye to my lambs
it's the final day for my flock at 17
weeks
my lambs are old enough to go to the
slaughter
i've been a sheep farmer for three and a
half months and it couldn't have been
any more eventful
one of my sheep died at birth and then
my lamb charlotte was mysteriously
killed
at the beckhams
[Music]
gavin is the only original member of my
flock still alive
i like gavin the most he's really
friendly
he's living in my garden along with two
french lambs which will play charlotte
three weeks ago i called the other two
the ugly two because they are ugly
but on the day of the slaughter there's
a final twist
gavin's been diagnosed with pneumonia
and been prescribed antibiotics
official regulation state alam can't be
slaughtered for a month after these kind
of injections
so at the last minute gavin has escaped
slaughter
hey buddy we had the most amazing recipe
for shepherd's pie
and you evaded it come on he's saved
luckily for me the two purebred lambs
are good for the chop
so we load them up for their final
journey we can't leave gavin alone in
our garden
so he's coming too gavin you are one
lucky little boy mate i tell you
huh hey hey
oh dear here we go again
you've never actually been inside a
avatar no i think it's one of those
situations where i don't quite know how
i'm going to find it
hello mark good morning are you well i'm
well good to see you
getting off the trailer for you okay
great
[Music]
uh mark it's quite a quick process yes
yeah very quick
i'm not very good when it comes to these
kind of situations um it's done
instantly
20 seconds from stun to stick time
maximum
okay
i'm gonna put the electric tongs on yes
you if you hold them steady
okay they're gonna fall over induce an
epileptic fit
chained up and then put on the elevator
and go upstairs and you can follow it up
right and watch me stick and make
something in terms of the
emotional impact you know they've been
in the garden but they're new arrivals
so
thankfully i'm not attached purposely i
didn't get close to them watching
being part of it now yeah it's crucial
for me right but it's awful when you see
them just before it's going to happen
yeah i'm going to be holding my lambs as
they are stunned with tongs that charge
to 200 volts
okay let go
the shock stuns the lamb so they feel no
pain when their throat is cut
it's so professionally done it's quick
that's the most important yeah i'm just
having done within seconds that's great
that's just nerves danny last thing on
my mind right now is [ __ ] shepherd's
pie
ready moments later my second lamb is
slaughtered the same
way a very very odd experience i mean
very traumatic i think when you when you
just see you know one minute you've got
this live
van wiggling around next minute that's
it
i really wanted to learn all i could
about what happens after the lambs are
killed
we start by skinning them it's an
incredibly skilled job
the initial cuts are called ripping
lines because they're ripping through
the skin
and that was just brute force so you
push over
both sides i'm really just pulling
the sheath out of the wall really yeah
it's amazing how hot the animal is yeah
hold it there and push and put that hand
on there as well
and push towards the wall come on push
lean on it lean on
the rest of the skin is removed by
machine to save time
unbelievable i mean the lamb is
fantastic now does it in terms of
quality wise
yeah so next stage evisceration
takes it up over god
you got the lungs the liver there the
heart yeah but the liver is amazing that
look at the liver
it does look very healthy doesn't it as
a kidney i'm amazed how hot they are
yeah
it's hard to believe that you know
literally five minutes ago these things
were rolling around straight yeah
yeah all meat slaughtered in the uk is
examined by government inspectors
if the carcass passes it gets a stamp of
approval
one final job i've promised you've
earlier would install the brains
to cook with i don't want the brain full
of [ __ ] skull
yeah a little shrapnel
on top of the cranial cavity there you
go there's the brain exposed
that's good and there you have the brain
they're beautiful huh no bits of skull
guard amazing you're still [ __ ] warm
thinking about what process yeah thank
you very much awesome it's been a
really big eye-opener i can relate to it
now because that's how we
get it that's how we would arrive at
claridges
straight from the farm now
time to start thinking about burning out
the legs breaking it down the rack the
neck
good a good pair of lambs there
okay jb results for the dessert yes the
amount of ladies
that are happy to pay for desserts [ __ ]
me
16 out of 50. what 16. what do they say
um two alcoholic two alcoholic yeah the
girl what's wrong with that
that's the most hilarious thing i've
heard all [ __ ] yeah you know that so
total that is 75 out of 150
sadly in the end four ex-army officers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]